well skies technology correspondent Tom
cheshire is with me some of the Chinese
authorities are saying we shouldn't jump
to conclusions but clearly the American
authorities believe they've got enough
evidence build a pointer finger well
exactly they said it would be
irresponsible they didn't deny the
attack either but the thing it's quite
rare for and I could come out a name
China as the recipient but this is
happening the whole time behind us this
is a map from a cyber security company
called Norse and this shows all the ddos
attacks happening right now DDoS attack
is when you overwhelm a server with
loads of requests which brings it down
and you can see how and this is
happening and up in the top here this is
where attacks are originating from lots
from china up there but then united
states is a second so they're giving as
good as they're taking so this is always
happening the US government is working
with cyber weapons so the famous one was
Stuxnet which puts an Iranian nuclear
facility offline for a bit the Iranians
claimed that last month they also hacked
by the Americans an oil refinery was
attacked so everyone's doing this is
quite rare though for a country to come
out and say someone has hacked us and
again there's a problem just because it
happened in China and they're saying
these were Chinese hackers those could
be criminals those could be people
working in the government agency they
have a huge cyber division over there or
it could be a mixture of the two it
could be criminals with the aid of
intelligence agencies so online it's all
really hard to tease out so the fact
that the United States of conant said
this is China is quite a big deal and
how easy is it going to be for the
American authorities to be able to stem
the flow well if they say they detected
in April but the hackers have been in
there since last year and this is where
hacks work a lot you gain access and
then you you try and keep as quiet as
possible snoop around once you've scoped
out the sort of facilities then you make
off with all the data and that's when
people realize so they'll be hoping to
stop it and they just first well they
need to find out exactly what's been
taken what data has been lost and it
sounds like it could be up to 4 million
records of quite sensitive personal
information but it is only one trove
last month as well we had the hack of
adult friend finder which is a private
website it was hacked by a private
individual who's offering that database
for sale for 20 million dollars to the
highest bidder or you can get a look at
it for sixteen thousand dollars now that
is a private individual who's done that
but their US senators on there there are
British MPs apparently from people
who've seen the database they tell
me there British MPs on there so that
could also be useful the same sort of
information of actually a lot more
personal so to make this distinguish
between government and private again in
this messy online world that we have
here those distinctions aren't so useful
anymore